les archives départementales de la
Réunion détiennent une riche collection
de cartes et plantes j'ai choisi de vous
présenter une carte de Bourbon de 1763
c'est une carte gravée rehaussée
d'aquarelle dressé par le sien Belin qui
était ingénieur de la marine par ordre
de monsieur le duc de Choiseul qui était
ministre de la guerre et de la marine
cette carte nous présente un tableau
précis de l'occupation de l'île à la fin
du XVIIIe siècle
après 100 ans de présence française
Bourbon est une colonie peuplée dans
toutes les régions littorales sont mises
en valeur les hauts ne sont plus des
terres inconnues le chemin de
Saint-Benoît à Cilaos par la Plaine des
Cafres et tracer les trois salades et la
plaine de Cilaos sont également situés
les principales rivières que nous
connaissons actuellement sont indiqués
sur la carte la rivière du mal la
Rivière des Roches la rivière d'abord ou
la rivière Saint-Étienne la population
de Lille a régulièrement augmenté depuis
l'installation
détienne régnaux et de ses compagnons en
le recensement de
1761 donne une population totale de
23000 personnes la colonie se compose
alors de 8 quartiers
Saint-Denis Saint-Paul Saint-Benoît
Sainte-Suzanne Saint-André Sainte Marie
Saint-Pierre et Saint-Louis le quartier
de Saint-Paul est le plus considérable
et le plus peuplé de l'île écrit le père
Pingré en 1761 avec la bourdonnée le
rôle de Bourbon comme base de
ravitaillement en vivre et en homme et
nettement marqué après une période de
prospérité nombre d'habitants de l'île
vont souffrir cependant durant le
conflit franco-anglais et ils verront
leur niveau de vie s'effondrer
la communauté blanche va alors ce
scinder en deux groupes les
copropriétaires et les petits blancs